it's with great pleasure that i welcome
all of you to today's colloquium
this promises to be a very rewarding
session because mr bevin alexander
will be discussing his critically
acclaimed and most recent work
how hitler could have won world war ii
a special welcome and vote of thanks
must therefore first go to mr alexander
not only for his contributions to the
longwood community over these past
nine years but also for allowing us to
host this very special event
and i'd also be remiss if i did not
offer special thanks to the managers and
the film crew
of c-span 2's book tv who are here today
to film this program
and to share it with a national audience
mr bevin alexander is well known to the
students and faculty of our campus
as a dedicated teacher extraordinary
lecturer
and brilliant historian he has
consistently displayed the ability
through combining his encyclopedic
knowledge of military history
with the finest qualities of the
historical storyteller
to make history come alive for his
classes
and paying him the highest compliment
any student body can pay a professor
his courses are consistently in demand
and are always filled to overflowing
mr alexander who holds a bachelor of
arts degree from the citadel
and a master of arts degree in
journalism from from northwestern
university
has had a lifelong love of military
history and professional writing
this was evident very early in his life
when at the age of 23
he enlisted in the united states army
and served in the korean war
as commander of the army's fifth
historical detachment
in the course of becoming one of our
nation's foremost combat historians he
was awarded three battle stars
and his work is now included in the
official history
of the united states army in korea
upon returning from the war mr alexander
came to virginia
and began a highly successful career in
journalism
he subsequently worked as a reporter for
the richmond times dispatch
and instructor of journalism at virginia
commonwealth university
editor of rural virginia magazine and
director of information at the
university of virginia
in 1966 he changed direction and he was
made executive vice president
of the virginia hotel and motel
association
a position he held until he retired in
1982
it was in retirement that mr bevin
returned full-time to his first love
the study of military history his
subsequent work in that area has earned
him recognition
as one of our nation's leading experts
in military leadership
and strategy in addition to teaching at
longwood and being in constant demand on
the lecture circuit
he has published no fewer than seven
books
including the one he will discuss today
they number
among them robert e lee's civil war
published in 1998
the future of warfare in 1995
another book in 1995 lost victories the
military genius of stonewall jackson
and how great generals win in 1993
and finally korea the first war
we lost in 1986.
it is testimony to his skill that each
of these works was well received by both
the professional historical community
and the reading public and so it is with
great pleasure that i give you mr
alexander bevin
who will discuss with us his newest work
how
hitler could have won world war ii
thank you thank you dr cormier i'm
honored to be associated with the
splendid institution of higher learning
mark twain once was having dinner with a
proud and
self-important man the man drew himself
up and announced did you know that
sugar is the only word in the english
language
spelled s-u and pronounced s-h
mark twain turned to the man and replied
are you sure
i wonder whether we are always sure
about how wars are won and lost
we recognize that the world's political
structure and to a large degree
its social structure came about as a
result of war
we understand that americans gained
their independence in one war
and were forged into a single people and
another
yet as important as warfare is
in resolving human conflict
it's not always apparent that in every
war
military or political leaders make
profound
solitary decisions these decisions can
have critical
and lasting effects in not a few cases
leaders make them in defiance of the
advice they receive
and sometimes their decisions are so
flawed
that they lose the war let me cite two
examples
confederate general james longstreet
showed
robert e lee the southern commander
how to win the battle of gettysburg
move the confederate army just to the
south he
he told lee interposing it between
washington
and the union army
this will force the union commander to
abandon his impregnable position on
cemetery ridge
and obligate him to attack the
confederate army directly
we will win long street set but lee
refused
insisted on headlong hopeless assaults
against union forces
on cemetery ridge and thereby lost
the civil war chinese communist premier
zou in lai
informed president harry truman in
october 1950
that the chinese would intervene in the
korean war
if american forces crossed the 38th
parallel
truman was so excited up by the american
victory in the incheon invasion a couple
weeks before
that he ignored zohan life and sent
american forces into north korea
as a result the korean war lasted
another two and a half years
cost the lives of hundreds of thousands
of men
and ended along virtually the same line
that american forces were standing
when zo and lai made his statement
for the past half century the main
thrust of study
of the second world war has portrayed
adolf hitler
as a madman germany has overmatched
and the victory of the allies as
inevitable
most analyses of hitler himself have
focused
on the holocaust his attempt to murder
the jews of europe
this is understandable adolf hitler was
one of
the most evil monsters the world has
ever known
and his fixation on the final solution
so rightfully horrified people
everywhere
that most writers attempted to fathom
why
he possessed such malignant prejudices
yet in the end they concluded that evil
is inexplicable
that what drove hitler to the
unspeakable depths
he reached can never be plumbed
the source of the hate that blackened
the heart of adolf hitler
remains as obscure and enigmatic as ever
today it's not easy to resurrect the
intense clutch of
fear that gripped the world 60 years ago
i was a boy growing up during the war
and i remember
vividly the terror everyone felt that
germany
might win the horrible world
hitler wanted to create was not then
some unreal bad dream but a clear and
present
danger the victory of freedom over
tyranny was a near thing
as i have tried to show in my book the
outcome outcome could just as well gone
the other way
i have approached world war ii by asking
this question
how close did we come to losing
my starting point is a fact no one
disputes
that hitler though most certainly mad
also possessed high intelligence great
qualities as a leader
and immense political sense in the seven
years
from the time he became dictator of
germany in 1933
to mid-summer 1940 hitler made
practically no mistakes
during this period he isolated and
absorbed state after state in europe
gained the soviet union as a willing
ally
destroyed france's military power
through the british off the continent
and was left with only weak and
vulnerable obstacles
to an empire embracing most of europe
north africa
and the middle east this empire not only
would have been unassailable from the
outside
but would have put him into the position
in time to conquer
the world a number of high german
officers
showed hitler time after time how he
could achieve such an invincible
position
and showed him how he could do it using
only a tiny fraction of germany's
military power
one of these advisors was eric rader
chief of the german navy
another was irving rommel the famous
desert fox commander in north africa
yet hitler ignored the admonitions of
raider
rommel and others and embarked on a
course of action
that guaranteed his defeat in five years
the thousand-year reich was shattered
and hitler did
why this happened is the subject of my
book
the fundamental reason is quite
astounding hitler decided after
germany's victory over france
in 1940 that he was an infallible
military genius having reached this
conclusion
hitler decided that he could rely
entirely on his intuition
this intuition told him to downgrade the
war against
britain and to turn to destruction of
the soviet union
hitler had hated the soviet union since
its beginning after the russian
revolution of 1917
and his obsession to destroy it was
scarcely less intense
than his obsession to this to destroy
the jews
in addition hitler wanted laban's round
or living space
for the german people and intended to
get it
by killing or starving millions of slavs
in the soviet union to make room for
german settlers
yet hitler's military commanders knew
that the war in the west
had been only half white and few thought
it could be finished on the plains
of russia in the east the soviet union
was so vast
that a war there could expand into
limitless space
placing potentially impossible demands
on the german war machine
a war against russia would be nothing
like the war in the west
where distances were limited populations
concentrated
objectives close and the atlantic ocean
a finite
boundary the question occurs then
why did hitler decide he was a military
genius
he did not arrive at this conclusion on
the strength of military education
hitler had little of that he had been a
front-line soldier in the first world
war
but had risen only to the rank of
corporal
hitler's reappears but reappraisal of
his military qualifications
came about in quite a different way
the general staff the planning and
operations branch of the german army
its intellectual core was made up of
highly professional
highly trained officers the general
staff
was responsible for most of the
victories germany had gained in the past
70 years
but the general staff now joined with
the army commander
in the over commando desjeres the okh
or army high command was also composed
of orthodox
soldiers they had studied how wars had
been fought
in the past and generally concluded they
would be fought the same way
in the future the okh
was not unique the high commands of both
the french and british
armies thought along the same
conventional lines
as might have been expected the okh
conceived a quite orthodox method
to defeat france and britain the attack
could not come anywhere across the
franco-german frontier
in the 1930s france had constructed the
maginot line
from switzerland to luxembourg the
maginot line
was a barrier of interconnected
reinforced
concrete fortifications and casemated
cannons
that could not be overcome by direct
attack
this meant the offensive had to come
through belgium
the okh accordingly developed a plan
for a massive direct strike into
northern belgium
and holland with the idea of driving the
british and french armies
back into france astonishingly
the plan did not call for the
destruction of the allied armies
only that they be forced to retreat to
give germany space
to pursue an air and sea war against
britain
the plan accorded an important but not
decisive job
to a new kind of force armored or panzer
divisions
the panzers had been developed by a
low-ranking general
heinz gadarian over the objections of
the general staff
guderian had concentrated all german
tanks into panzer divisions
instead of parceling them out in penny
packets
to infantry divisions as was and
remained
the practice in the british and the
french armies
guderian only achieved this victory
because adolf hitler
became enthusiastic about tanks
at an exercise in 1933
and supported guderian's idea
in the plan of the okh the tanks would
merely
assist traditional infantry divisions
supported by field artillery
in driving the british and the french
into retreat
the allied high commands anticipated the
german plan
it was the logical solution of every
orthodox
soldier the allies intended to block
the german advance by rushing their most
mobile forces
which were entrenched along the belgian
frontier to the dial river
about 15 miles east of the belgian
capital of brussels
the okh also spotted the dial as the
defensive
allied line therefore
both the german and allied high commands
intended to collide in a huge frontal
battle
along the dial river
when eric von phone manstein saw the
german plan
he was horrified it paid little heed
to the immense offensive power of the
new panzer divisions
and would lead to stalemate and a war of
attrition
which germany could not win van stein
was chief of staff to army group a
under a geared fund runestet and he
developed an entirely different
plan concentrate the bulk of germany's
ten
panzer divisions opposite the yard arden
a heavily forested region of low
mountains
in eastern belgium and northern
luxembourg
the roads in this region were narrow
steep and crooked
no one expected an attack there but
goddarian assured manstein
that that his tanks could easily
negotiate the roads
a thrust through the ardennes would come
along the line of least expectation
drive to sudan on the muse river in
northern france
manstein advised cross the river before
the french
could build a defensive barrier then
turn
west and rush straight for the english
channel
160 miles away since the british and
french forces
meanwhile would have streamed up to the
dial
there would be virtually nothing to stop
this drive
when the panzers reached the channel
they would have cut off all the allied
troops in belgium
forcing them to surrender with the most
mobile
allied formations eliminated the defeat
of france would be assured
but the okay h didn't like manstein's
idea first of all
they were angry because he wanted to
toss out their plan
second they were orthodox soldiers
panzer divisions had been employed only
once before
in 1939 against weak polish forces
armed with obsolete weapons the french
and british armies
by contrast were modern powerful and
extremely dangerous
to bet the entire campaign in the west
on tanks and surprise
was more than the o-k-h could stomach
accordingly they stonewalled
since manstein continued to push for his
plan
they transferred him to command of an
infantry corps with only a walk-on role
in the upcoming campaign they hoped
manstein would disappear
and the okh could go on with its
original idea
however manstein used the opportunity of
a luncheon
hitler held for new corps commanders to
talk privately with the fuhrer
hitler at once saw that manstein's idea
could bring victory
and the next day ordered the okh to
adopt it
the result was that budarian broke
through at sedan
in only four days reached the english
channel a week
later and cut off all the allied armies
in belgium
those allied soldiers who did not
surrender were forced to evacuate by sea
at dunkirk
a month later france capitulated and the
british were thrown onto their islands
with few weapons and only 21 miles of
the channel to keep them from being
conquered as well
germany had achieved the most
spectacular rapid and overwhelming
victory
in the 20th century it dominated europe
from the north cape of norway
to the mediterranean sea and from poland
to the atlantic ocean
it was this victory that convinced
hitler that he was a military genius
he had been right the okh wrong
he forgot that the idea was not his but
eric von mannstein's
and that the implementation of that idea
was not his
but heinz guderian's hitler's acceptance
of manstein's plan
was the best military decision he ever
made
what's bizarre is that it was
practically the only
great military decision hitler made
almost without exception his other major
decisions were wrong
and contributed directly to his defeat
in other words it was not the strength
of the allies
that guaranteed the destruction of nazi
germany
it was the disastrous decisions that
hitler himself made
from 19 mid 1940 onward after he had
decided that he was a military genius
his fatal error was to attack the soviet
union
in a direct headlong assault on the main
strength of the red army
yet throughout the last half of 1940 and
the first half of 1941
raider and other officers pleaded with
hitler
to follow another path to victory
the way was not through a frontal attack
on the soviet union
but an indirect approach through north
africa
this route was so obvious that not only
did raider
rommel and other german officers see it
but so did all the british leaders
after the destruction of france's
military power
britain was left with only a single
armored division to protect
egypt and the suez canal
germany now had 20 armored divisions
none being used
if germany and its ally italy the axis
powers
had employed only four of these panzer
divisions to seize the suez canal
the british royal navy would have been
compelled to withdraw from the
mediterranean sea
this would have made supply to the
british island of malta too difficult
forcing the british to give up this base
only 60 miles south of sicily
and on the direct supply line between
italy and its colony
libya with the royal navy gone
and malta abandoned the mediterranean
would turn into an
axis lake this would permit the germans
to occupy french north africa
morocco algeria and tunisia and allow
german forces to seize dakar
in senegal on the west coast of africa
from dakar submarines and aircraft could
dominate
the south atlantic sea routes with no
hope of aid
yugoslavia and greece would be compelled
to come to terms
since hitler was gaining hungary romania
and bulgaria
as allies germany germany could achieve
control of all southeastern
europe without committing a single
german soldier
once the suez canal was taken the way
would be opened for german armored
columns
to overrun palestine transjordan the
arabian peninsula syria
iraq and iran britain had few troops in
this region
this would give germany unlimited
supplies of the commodity it needed most
oil as important as oil was for
the conduct of modern war the greatest
advantages of german occupation of the
arab lands
in iran would be to isolate turkey
threaten british control of india and
place german tanks and aircraft
within striking distance of the soviet
oil fields in the caucasus
and along the shores of the caspian sea
turkey would be forced to become an ally
or grant transit rights to german forces
britain would have to exert all its
strength to protect india
and the soviet union would go to any
lengths to preserve peace with germany
because of its perilous position
unless the strength of the soviet union
were added
the united states could not have
projected sufficient military
force across the atlantic ocean even
over a period of years
to reconquer europe by amphibious
invasion
in the face of an untouched german war
machine
since the united states was increasingly
preoccupied with
the threat of japan it almost certainly
would not have challenged germany
thus germany would have been left with a
virtually invincible empire
and the leisure to develop defenses and
resources that in time
could match the strength of the united
states
though britain might have refused to
make peace
a de facto ceasefire would have ensued
the united states would have
concentrated
on the defense of the western hemisphere
and the pacific
even if the united states had proceeded
with the development of the atomic bomb
it would have hesitated to unleash it
against germany
hitler however rejected raider's plan to
seize french north africa
and the suez canal he could not see the
way to victory that raider pointed out
to him
even in the spring of 1941 when ervin
rummel with a tiny german force
threw the entire british army in egypt
into headlong flight
hitler refused the small additional
strength he needed
to drive on to alexandria and suez and
force the royal navy out of the
mediterranean
and instead of capturing malta for which
british warship from which
british warships submarines and aircraft
constantly sank axis supply ships
enroute to libya
hitler used his highly trained
airborne troops to seize the virtually
useless island of crete
this decision cost hitler the war
on june 22nd 1941 he launched a frontal
invasion of the soviet union
here again his strategy was completely
flawed the people of the soviet union
had been oppressed for two decades
by the communist autocracy millions had
been killed
others sent to horrible prison gulags in
siberia
and most of the remainder forced to work
long hours under terrible conditions
to transform the soviet union into an
industrial state
in addition the soviet union was an
empire ruling over a collection of
subjugated peoples
who were violently opposed to rule from
the kremlin
if hitler had gone into the soviet union
as a liberator
instead of a conqueror the vast numbers
of people would have risen in rebellion
and the soviet union would have
collapsed
instead hitler went into the soviet
union union with precisely the opposite
policy
he ordered the immediate shooting of all
communist officials
or commissaries and all gorillas or
partisans since anyone
could be designated a commissar or a
partisan
the germans had free reign to kill any
prisoner and did so in huge numbers
the germans also made no plans to feed
the russians they captured or overran
expecting millions to starve
finally directly behind the german field
forces
hitler sent in einsatzgruppen or
extermination detachments
to hunt down and murder jews these acts
arouse the patriotism of the
russian people and the fierce resolve to
drive the germans out of their land
hitler's policy was totally
counterproductive and contributed
greatly to the defeat of the german army
beyond these burdens hitler laid out
impossible tasks for the army to
accomplish
he ordered the army to seize leningrad
or st petersburg in the north
moscow in the center and ukraine and the
oil fields of the caucasus
in the south and to do all this before
the onset of the russian winter
hitler expected to conquer a million
square miles of soviet territory the
first year
that's a region the size of the united
states east of the mississippi
the job he gave his soldiers was like
invading the east coast of the united
states and in less than six months
reaching montreal in the north st louis
and the center
and new orleans and the south this
effort diverging in three directions
over hundreds of miles
was bound to fail when it finally
collapsed
before moscow in december 1941 in the
face of snow
ice bitter cold and a soviet
counter-offensive
there was no hope thereafter that
germany could win the war
the enormous size of russia the shortage
of german manpower
and the resurgence of the red army all
converged
the moment of possible victory had
passed for germany
hitler had gotten himself into this
situation because he had three
blind spots that crippled his decision
making
he did not really understand the
magnificent offensive weapon
that guderian had created for him in the
panthers
he could not conceive of a broad
strategic plan
that would lead to victory and because
he was convinced of his own military
wisdom
he rejected the superb strategic plans
proposed to him by raider
rommel and others yet a negotiated peace
was still possible
the campaigns in the what in the east
had proved that german panzers
were virtually unstoppable when they
maneuvered freely across the great open
spaces of russia and ukraine
the proper decision after the attempt to
conquer the soviet union failed
was to make strategic withdrawals to
create fluid
conditions so panzers could carry out
wide movements
and surprise attacks this would have
given maximum
effect to the still superior quality
of german command staffs and fighting
troops
and almost certainly would have
prevented the russians from
recovering large amounts of german
occupied territory
to regain control of his country the
soviet dictator joseph stalin
likely would have concluded a peace with
hitler
if the soviet union dropped out of the
war the western allies might have
negotiated a piece as well
but hitler rejected anything less than
total victory
he refused to allow a fluid defensive
stance in the east
instead he insisted on continued attacks
that aid up most of his remaining
offensive power
at the same time he ordered his troops
to defend every inch of ground they
seized
when soviet counter-offensive struck
many of these defenders were lost
these policies offensive too weak to
succeed
and hopeless defense of every position
led among other disasters
to the sacrifice of an entire army at
stalingrad
a quarter of a million men
the world can be grateful that adolf
hitler deceived and deceived himself
into thinking he was a military genius
because of this arrogance he disregarded
advice from other
commanders who could have won the war
for him
hitler himself and the criminal state he
created
finally died by his own false pride and
belief in his own omniscience
thank you very much appreciate the
opportunity for you
um first off my grandfather served in
the korean war
in the third armor division and my
question for you today
is uh do you believe macarthur was
punished accordingly
um by our by the president
do you believe he is punished
accordingly
after the korean war for his parade in
new york city
was punished withdrawn from korea by the
president he
this president you're asking me do i
think that that
macarthur was was punished correctly by
being ousted by
president truman is that your question
absolutely it was he was
he was absolutely justified by being uh
president truman did exactly the right
thing
uh this is about this is about world war
ii by the way
um but um while we're talking about the
korean war um
uh he tried to take over uh control of
american foreign policy himself
by himself and he tried to he tried to
get the chinese
to into the war and he also wanted to
attack
china directly and use the atomic bomb
all of these would have been disastrous
for the united states
so he was truman was absolutely correct
and and ousting him in april 1951.
yes
as the magnitude of hitler's mistakes
became apparent and it certainly should
have become apparent to him after the
russian campaign
did he ever reflect upon those mistakes
i'm interested in what was his mindset
there was a period of
decay where was getting progressively
worse do we have any information
about his yeah about that matter of fact
the
diaries of of all the people who were
close to hitler uh
have detail after detail about that that
you made a comment with the implication
that he began to degenerate after that
period i don't know that there's any
proof of that
i think probably his ideas his brain was
probably just as good
then as it ever had been i think the
great mistake and when you look at the
history
of of what happened in world war ii the
great mistake was
hubris he suddenly came up with hubris
after the victory in in 1940 with france
and suddenly said okay i'm i'm great and
i don't believe his brain actually uh
declined in
in at all during that period but his his
decision-making was absolutely false as
i say in my talk
from that point on and he did not listen
to anyone
from that point on it's interesting uh
here he listened to manstein on one
little
luncheon conversation i mean we we we
know about this this is documented
but then einstein goes to him time after
time
when he was a army group commander in in
europe
and uh in russia and tries to tell him
don't do this don't do this don't
do this and in every single case hitler
turned him down
why we you have to ask the question why
did he suddenly decide or
or certainly over a period of a year or
two decide that he
no longer had to listen to einstein and
i think the only answer you can give
is that he had come to the conclusion
that he had made this wonderful decision
in 1940 and he must be right about
everything
with the german uh my questions about
german naval policy during the war
um it seemed to be like the german
policy to send out uh
their ships like kind of piecemeal like
with the bismarck and the prince oregon
uh was there ever a time where the
german navy could have gone out
and slugged it out with the british uh
navy and perhaps
could have defeated them with help of
air cover
uh never there's never a moment that
they could ever have done that
the british navy was so incredibly
superior
with surface ships and you talked about
at this stage of the war battleships
aircraft carrier did not come in as a
critical issue for about another year
there was no possibility the bismarck
went out almost alone
the other ships went out they did not
have this the the
the naval support necessary to to
challenge the royal navy there was never
any possibility that's why they went to
the uber
u-boats you see they had no they could
not put their surface their surface of
weapons were
completely inadequate and that's one
reason why
it's so it's astonishing when you look
at the history of the uh world war
ii is there was no need for germany to
have a navy at all
there was no need even to have u-boats
actually
i mean they could they could certainly
have used them at dakara i'm not saying
they shouldn't but
uh but the fact is they did not have to
have a navy
because if they had captured the
mediterranean it would have no longer
been in naval war
do you think that do you think that if
churchill had negotiated with hitler at
munich
the outcome of the war might have been
different
instead of instead of chamberlain it's
an interesting question
it had been a lot more exciting i can
say that
the speeches would have been a lot
better neville chamberlain came back and
said i
have peace in our time which was one of
the stupidest statements that ever been
stated by any
any prime minister in history no
it was not possible nobody could have
stopped hitler in 1938
and it's absolutely impossible as a
matter of fact hitler was a little bit
mad that he was not allowed
to attack czechoslovakia he wanted to
attack czechoslovakia
he wanted to show the world how powerful
he was now he was wrong
at that stage because he had a tough
time but his actual mindset in 1938
at munich was to attack czechoslovakia
so
no it would not have changed anything
had the plot to assassinate hitler
in the wolf's lair succeeded 44
what kind of terms do you think the
allies
might have been willing to extend the
germans
that's a question i don't think we'll
ever answer thoroughly
you know you start from the premise
which i'm sure you're all aware of that
at
casablanca roosevelt and churchill
decided on the
doctrine of unconditional surrender
therefore
we were saddled with the concept of
unconditional surrender of the german
army now most people think that this
led the germans onward onward on and
into um
to more and more greater defense and
that's not really true no it's no
there's no evidence of that whatsoever
and a lot of people do not know the real
reason why roosevelt
and churchill did that they did it only
to tell joseph stalin that that the
western allies were not going to have a
separate peace
this was to keep the soviet union in the
war that was the only reason for
unconditional surrender in the final
analysis now so you come down to say
1944 and a man is killed
you're assuming that is that your charge
all right there was a large
group of people thinking at that stage
that the german army would surrender to
the
allies in the west and they would then
they would join up
and be great big buddies and go off and
attack the communists in the east
this is so totally absurd that uh you'd
sometimes just laugh at it but
there was a lot of thought in this
direction and the germans actually a
good number of them actually thought
that this might come about
but i don't believe was ever any
possibility uh they're what you
maybe know i'm sure some of some of you
do know that
there was an effort by rommel and some
of the other people
in 1940 after the normandy invasion to
to have a a cease-fire
in the west in other words given on the
west stop fighting the
western allies and would continue to
fight in the east
i don't believe this would have changed
anything and the the
the history of the time and the
documentation of the time
says that eisenhower was absolutely
opposed to that that possibility because
he would see this as a way to divide and
conquer
and that was the that was what they were
absolutely determined not to do
so i don't think would have made any
difference i really don't
yes
uh mr alexander how much effect did
ultra have
on divining german intentions
ultra as you probably all know was the
breaking of the enigma
uh encoding machine that the germans
developed
actually in 1929 and the germans were so
proud of this machine
that they assumed that it could never be
broken uh this is one thing that
astonishes me in in looking at germany
he was a very
outstanding nation a very advanced
nation that thought well
we came up with this code and nobody can
break this code it had been
it was actually the machine was stolen
or somehow another acquired by poles
in 1939 and uh bletchley and in
bletchley in
england in a in a old manor house
a group of very intelligent
mathematicians
began breaking the code early early and
the war
uh they never broke the gestapo code
they broke the luftwaffe
air force the german air force code very
quickly that's why they were successful
in the in the war in britain
the war the air war in britain in 1940
because they broke the code
um the question
in my mind is whether it
it definitely helped the allies to find
out
where things were going in advance
but by the time it became truly useful
the the allies in any particular theater
where they were were so powerful so
overwhelmingly powerful
in terms of strength to the german
forces that in most cases it did not
make a decisive difference
so i don't think we can say that it made
a decisive difference
there's a famous case which uh always
strikes me when you start relying too
much on
on on intelligence that um
the famous battle of kasserine passed in
1943 in tunisia
the uh allies through ultra had decided
that uh
the the attack of the germans was going
to be at a pass about 40 miles
north of where it actually took place
and that's why rommel
who who led the katharine attack was
able to get and nearly
if he had gotten if he hadn't had such
bad support from other germans he could
very well have
surrounded and wiped out a large portion
of the allied army in tunisia
so there was a mistake in the other
direction but it was
very important but it was not crucial
yes sir following uh the defeat at
stalingrad in early 1943
was there something that hitler could
have done to create a stalemate if not
victory on the eastern front
any type of strategic change or tactical
change or was defeat inevitable after
the defeat at stalingrad
no it was not inevitable that's a good
question it was not inevitable in fact
manstein
the same guy who who came up with the
idea to victory france came to
to hitler immediately after stalingrad
and proposed a dramatic
strategic plan he said
at that stage if to reconstruct it a bit
for you
the the german sixth army which was down
to by this stage about 9 8 000 men but
had already had started 250 000
was surrounded and was going to die at
stalingrad no way that could have been
saved
but the problem was that there was an
army group in the caucasus
several hundred miles into the caucasus
uh
manstein's army group which had been
saddled with the job of trying to save
stalingrad and hitler wouldn't let him
was another small army group that was in
that same region
and the soviets were
quite aware that all they had to do to
cut off both of those armies army groups
would be to drive
straight down to rostov on the sea of
azov which is
was only about 150 or 200 miles away
and if they reach this if they reach
rostov these two army groups and the
caucasus
would be would be cut off and they would
be in a huge stalingrad
i mean when you're talking about
stalingrad this would have been a
million or more men who would have been
lost
and and this was the great danger that
the germans faced after stalingrad
manstein goes to hitler and says let's
we we can't keep the caucasus anyway we
can't keep this region
anyway let's withdraw uh in a very
measured way
to the west and when we get about to the
deneber river which was several hundred
miles west
by this time that the soviets will
absolutely insist upon attacking after
us
this will leave an enormous area to the
west
that they have advanced into we will
assemble an army at kharkov which is to
the northwest
and when they do that we'll drive
straight through and cut off the entire
force and this would change the entire
strategic balance
in the east and it would have happened
it could have happened but hitler
refused to do that and
what i said in my talk he could not
accept
anyone moving from a place it actually
conquered
or or captured and for this reason
no movements like this were possible for
hitler he could never accept it
he learned that in world war one you see
during that
stalemate on the western front where
everybody moved in inches
that's how he learned about warfare and
therefore he never learned beyond that
thank you i'm a devotee of um propaganda
i guess
charlie chaplin just watched the great
dictator
and you did elude in your opening
remarks to the effects
of the uh the third reich taking over
the world could you talk a little bit
about more about the effect in the
united states of
the threat of hitler and the threat felt
in the states and
some of the uh perhaps the way charlie
chaplin's filmed the great dictator
might have
eased some of the concerns or
not sure that's an interesting question
of course the great dictator came out
when in 1938
yeah 1938 and it turned hitler into
buffoon
as i'm sure you recall uh hitler was not
a buffoon now he did climb uh
he did climb curtains it turns out this
is true
there's some actual documentation of him
climbing curtains
and uh and he did uh froth at the mouth
but i frosted the mouth in front of my
students so
that's that's not necessarily uh an
indication of madness although it might
be
but i i think it i think the mistake we
made
at that period was to treat him as a
buffoon
instead of the huge danger that he was i
think that was a great
the great mistake we met but i i'd like
to add to that something that i recall
as i say i was a boy at the time
and i remember distinctly what was
actually taking place
in 1940 after france fell and i know
exactly what people were thinking and
the the the
withdrawal behind our two oceans was the
primary thought that we had in 1940 in
the united states
we wanted to back off the so-called
isolationist
movement we wanted to back off and
defend our
our island you see when people don't
quite understand americans actually
think of themselves as living on an
island
we actually think of ourselves as a as a
as an island nation
and if you think about it that's the
monroe doctrines whole concept
we're protecting our our hemisphere our
big island from all those invaders and
that's what washington was talking about
the monroe doctrine
all of that's based around the fact that
we have this island and only after world
war ii did we ever
break ourselves out of this isolationist
attitude and become world
world power so that with the world war
ii was the actual catalyst that did that
yes on the other side of the room we
have several questions
hi it's often said that churchill
considered the italian peninsula as a
soft underbelly of europe
did any of hitler's high command give
him any suggestions or
plans to really reinforce italy and uh i
guess prevent the eventual takeover of
europe by the allies
thanks i understand you correct your
question you mean was the
idea of going into italy a viable
argument for the allies as a strategic
move
uh was the reinforce were there any
suggestions for the reinforcement of
axis powers in italy and
to prevent the taking of italy by patton
and the allies
um it was not any great danger uh italy
any of you people have been to italy
know that it consists of one valley and
one mountain after another
and uh therefore uh there is not a very
it's not a very nice place to fight
a war and therefore the danger of
of a of the possibility of a victory
through
italy was always ephemeral it was always
a it was always
impossible now could we have
moved into the um through the tyrol
uh or maybe through uh through tries to
some region like that
at the top of the uh adriatic sea i
don't think so because you still had the
alps there and the alps are incredibly
difficult mountains
because you've gone through the balkans
well the balkans were at the tail end of
europe with terrible roads very few
railroads
and very very far from the heart of
germany so i don't believe there was a
possibility in that direction any
either the only possible other direction
you could have gone would be into
southern france and what
what what what's the advantage of that
you would have been you would have been
with the alps to your east
you'd have still had to go all the way
through france it would've been better
to
you're going to do that going in
normandy which is what they decided to
do
so no there was never there was never
any viable argument to go
through the soft underbelly of the axis
as churchill called
the mediterranean there was never any
way to win victory there we might have
gotten to a stalemate with germany but
germany
uh germany was the one that could have
achieved the stalemate we were trying
for victory
hi uh my quick question is uh why did
hitler order his uh forces to seize uh
fighting at uh dunkirk in uh 1940.
well if you can answer that question
you're going to get a you have a
bestseller i can tell you
that this is one of the great
imponderables of the world and nobody
knows why
uh to recapitulate it for you for just a
second
uh godarians panzers were with they were
at gravlin
which is what 10 miles from dunkirk
while the british and the french armies
were
35 or 40 miles to the east
in other words the panzers were already
at dunkirk
when hitler stopped them he stopped him
along the
the basee canal which was uh
10 or 8 or 10 or 12 miles south of
dunkirk
and the question is why um
hitler was a very uh
frightened man at this stage he was
more and more he got more and more
frightened every
step that the success of the germans got
more and more obvious
that he he could not believe it was
going to happen and it was happening so
fast gadarian was going so fast and
winning so incredibly quickly
that he began to try to put brakes on
the on the german army and actually did
but finally and but finally at the stage
at dunkirk
he um he put an order out that they
stopped
and there are two reasons that have been
advanced for this
one of them is somewhat logical and that
is that the panzers at this stage
the the battle had virtually been won
anyway the panzers needed to
to re replenish themselves and refurbish
and turn around to to conquer france
to the south so they had they had to
actually turn direction and move back
and that was necessary had to be done
the other thing was that uh
herman goering who was uh chief of the
luftwaffe of the air force
told hitler that his aircraft could
stop the british from evacuating french
and british and french as well
from evacuating from from dunkirk now
he didn't do it and we can get on that
just a second but the other
other argument that's been raised which
actually may be
the closer to the truth is that hitler
did not want to fight britain
that's not been very i didn't make that
plain in this talk today but
he wanted the british his allies he
wanted the british to keep their
empire and he wanted simply to have
complete control on the on the continent
of europe and he would let the british
have their empire and they'd be great
buddies and allies forever well of
course
britain couldn't remain an independent
country if it was um if
europe was under the control of nazi
germany and and the british
absolutely refused that but he didn't
hitler did not really
believe that they wouldn't see reason
and uh therefore come
to become allies of germany so the
argument has been
raised that he deliberately stopped the
german panzers
from from capturing dunkirk in order for
the british to
not lose 300 or 250 000 men
and get back and therefore they'd be so
grateful well of course
it had the opposite effect it became the
miracle of dunkirk
that you probably know about with the
british took little yachts civilian
people
ordinary ordinary british people went
out and took those soldiers
and took them back to uh to england in
tiny little boats
and uh that became the miracle of
dunkirk and actually
increased the resolve of the british to
continue the war
yes
um yes i was wondering about the status
of the german nuclear
or atomic program and why it was why was
stopped
if that could have proved to be a
valuable tool in their arsenal you know
etc
well the germans stopped before it got
very far they
they did some work with uh heavy water
and you probably know about that pina
munda was some tests going on
there the british knew about it and and
and made a preemptive strike on that
place i think in 1942
but the germans never did proceed
in the development of the atomic bomb so
it was never any possibility
during the time frame of the second
world war that the germans could have
ever developed the atomic bomb
now the question is would would they
have afterwards absolutely they were
but that at the stage of the war there
was never any possibility of it
they after all they kicked out all their
a large number of their
great nuclear people uh scientists were
were jews
and they kicked all those people out
albert einstein of course was not a
was not a nuclear physicist but uh he
was
he was the kind of person that they
kicked out of germany because it was
jews
so he he shot himself in the foot in
that direction as well
we'll take just two more questions dr
barber and then we'll take
gentlemen if d-day had failed
would hitler still have lost the war
you gave me two big gifts there um
if it had failed yeah he'd have lost a
war
he couldn't have won anyway at that
stage now we might have
taken a longer time to do it and we
might have begun to think
perhaps of some negotiated arrangement
but hitler even to the very last could
not conceive of
of a negotiated peace and if you think
about it you can understand that for a
second
he knew that he was murdering jews all
over europe the rest of the world didn't
really know that i mean there were there
was
information about it but the world as a
whole did not really know that he
the monstrous things he was doing in
europe and he knew that as soon as
anybody got to
to begin to look around europe they were
going to kill him
and he knew that there was no way he
could survive the war
in any kind of a negotiated arrangement
whatsoever so
long before this stage he knew that he
had either to win the war or die
and there were numerous things at the
last stage for example
in june of 1944 about the time that the
allies invaded
uh uh in normandy the russians got to
the uh
to the uh up to warsaw and poland
and at that stage it was no possibility
from that point on
of a german victory it was quite obvious
they had just lost a million men in the
retreat to warsaw into that region
the vistala river the line of the
vistula river
and a number of the german officers said
to him
we got to stop and he
he refused because he knew at that stage
there was no possibility of stopping he
had to go on to victory
so the last you can say really the last
seven or eight months of the war
was just to keep hitler alive that's
what you can say the last seven months
of war were to keep him alive
hitler wasn't the only one to have made
mistakes in the beginning of the second
world war
what was it about the allies that caused
them to
not recognize what hitler was about
early on
after all he had written his plan for
invading czechoslovakia and austria in
mein kampf which was written years
before
why were they not aware of his plans
well i don't know how to answer that
question
um why do why does anyone
not ex not take the evidence in front of
them i teach of course and some of you
students are here and you've heard me
already say
in my classes that one of the
astonishing things about warfare
is that in most wars you find exactly
that in front of you
that the evidence is right back in front
of your face and and if you use your
you're a noggin you can see that that
you can win or lose on the strength of
what's right in front of you
and so the answer to your question is
people do that people
just simply do not believe in um
in the in the evidence in front of their
faces uh you probably
recall there's with documentation uh
speeches uh articles throughout that
entire period saying well hitler really
is a reasonable man
and and i go back to what i said about
chamberlain he comes away
from having just been completely
bamboozled by adolf hitler
at munich and said we're going to have
peace in our time here was a chief of
the uh of the british government saying
believing this which was an absolute lie
and he
he should have known it everybody else
knew it i mean in theory they knew it
this is what i'm afraid is is the human
condition we want to believe
things that uh we want to believe
and if it's not a war it's better than a
war so we'll say okay
let's let's hope for that not being a
war and i think that's what brought on
world war one
excuse me world war ii was just that
simple hope and there was never a hope
really there was never hope from the
moment hitler became dictator of germany
in 1933.
uh thank you very much i appreciate very
much the opportunity to be informed
but
i know you probably don't want to hear
anything more i have to say forever
but there are copies of my talk if you'd
like to have me to end
i'm happy to have it thank you also i
just want to say
mr alexander there are many of us or at
least some of the people in this room
who lived through world war
ii i think many of us have struggled all
of our lives to try to understand this
war
and what i can tell you about today is
that i understand it a bit better
and i thank you so much for this it was
wonderful thank you